foreign
[Music]
really excited to have you here
hopefully there's not a post lunch slump
if anyone falls asleep I will totally
call you out so I'm just going to warn
you right now this is interactive I
appreciate you being here and I'm really
excited to talk about what it takes to
create a modern data platform
my name is Danielle Behringer that's
really awkward with a huge picture up
there so I'm just going to go to the
next slide I am a managing director at
KPMG in our data management and
Engineering practice
prior to KPMG I was the chief data
officer at a major Automotive for six
years that's like dog years that's a
really long time to be a chief data
officer but my background is as a data
engineer and software engineer across
industry and really all that means is
I'm a huge data nerd and I'm really
passionate about how the market is
changing and the ways that we can
reshape our future for people who want
to do more with data
I want to start with a definition of
data modernization this is a definition
that I believe is a huge change in how
we think about the way we use data for
Value it's a strategic approach for
Innovative use accessibility governance
operations and doing more in a modern
Cloud architecture through people
technology and process transformation
first things first by show of hands how
many of you are ready today for some
data therapy
yeah I know it hurts unfortunately a lot
of people aren't even self-aware that
they need it so what I wanted to start
with because no presentation at this
conference would be complete without
saying the words generated AI
I want to start with what are the what
are the prerequisites
if we don't create a modern data
ecosystem and go back to some of the
basics of the unsexy topics like data
quality
data governance oh I know it's not a
great term but it really matters so this
journey that I'm showing here Horizon
one two and three is about starting with
some self-reflection which is why I call
it data therapy how do you assess your
environment your portfolio the data
maturity of the folks that are working
every day with data potentially in
spreadsheets and they have no idea that
there's a better way you're trying to
build Cloud infrastructure deploy
application workloads and modernize your
data warehouses and data Lakes but
without doing it in Partnership between
the business and I.T it often fails
miserably
so if we return to some of the the heart
of the matter as we prepare to do
generative Ai and to get more business
value out of our data I want you to
think of this as a prerequisite the
topic of data modernization
challenges everyone's got them I work
for a Professional Services firm if
people didn't have challenges we would
have some problems right so if we look
at the top challenges we're seeing in
many cases it's technology proliferation
and the challenges for data
modernization are never about the
technology at least not most of the time
they're about the people and the process
they're about the adoption I like to say
that the presence of Technology does not
equal success but adoption does and it
has to be sustainable so when we look at
things like organizational resistance
data verification incorrect integration
some people call this like the
integration hairball it's a real thing
right
how do we move past that how do we start
to take people on the journey with us as
we're modernizing as they're maybe going
through a really long painful Erp
modernization or a finance
transformation how do we find those
opportunities with data to give them
something satiating while they're
waiting for a really long road map that
takes a lot of time and is very complex
so there are six things here that we see
as success criteria when we work with
our clients
when we see them changing their
organizations creating a data culture
creating data literacy but most
importantly having some very hard
painful conversations about data
minimization and Technology
simplification
we do not see organizations who have
Greenfield nothing they have a lot they
have business intelligence tools visual
analytics tools data wrangling tools
data science tools open source multiple
clouds
and a lack of integration consistency
and certainly a lack of operationally
sound sustained data ecosystems
so though I'm mentioning just in short
form business vision for data value
right do the business stakeholders
believe
that the data ecosystem can support
their vision for what they want to
accomplish in the business whether it's
a sales and marketing division that
wants to do more and maybe insource some
things that they've given to agencies
and partners maybe it's a supply chain
team that has zero visibility to data in
their manufacturing plan or anything
that's actually Ingress and egress out
of that plant to be successful with
supply chain
a modern layered architecture can be
extremely intimidating to people that
are not in the immediate perimeter of
I.T so how do we show it to them in a
way show them a portfolio that is based
on business value not just technological
definition or a bill of materials of 52
cloud services that they have to
assemble in order to make a widget right
data governance and literacy of course
is extremely important I actually think
data quality and data governance are
having a Renaissance because when people
went through gdpr and CCPA and they
realized that 72 copies of their
customer database lived around the
company and Joe every Thursday was
sending the customer database in an
Excel spreadsheet to a group of people
they were horrified but what it did was
it uncovered an opportunity to spend
more time on metadata management and
more time on a data catalog definitions
a data dictionary and certainly some
data minimization
so now here we are we want to pursue
generative AI everyone is super
comfortable with everything prompted the
expectation for clients is absolutely
changing they expect it to be easier
they expect to use natural language to
accomplish a task that previously before
required a lot of different steps in
data wrangling so Envision in a modern
data architecture some of the things
that are on the right but fundamentally
changing how people work I like to say
if they were spending 30 hours a week
data wrangling and cobbling things
together what would it do if that became
two hours
a lot of people worry that they would
lose their job they would be repurposed
I like to think that they get 28 hours
back to work on things they wouldn't
have gotten to for two years
they are pulling ahead all of those
valuable activities all that
value-driven consumption of data because
of optimization of the environment a
deeper understanding of the data
and an infrastructure and services that
make it easy and self-service for them
but also protect privacy and risk and
security
part of the data therapy again
self-awareness exercise it goes from
left to right the Baseline activities on
the left I am absolutely certain most of
you have this in place today in your
organizations traditional data
architecture logical and physical data
modeling
you know standards reference data these
are the table Stakes
to be doing data and analytics now
how many of you have ever played Super
Mario Brothers or have children or
family that okay good yay okay this is
just like Super Mario Brothers you don't
get to go to level five all the way on
the right until you pass through the
levels prior
it's very important so most people find
themselves somewhere in the middle they
have visual analytics tools they maybe
have a manually derived data catalog
they are starting to build a racy
whether it they have a cloud center of
excellence and maybe a data center of
excellence maybe they have a hybrid
model where itis is providing certain
data services data engineering data
science is normally Federated and is
found in the lines of business and
everyone is starting to work together
but to get to the items on the right
really takes a complete transformation
in the way that people are working
together their understanding of data as
a product and I'll talk a little bit
about that today
and then also taking full advantage of
the cloud native Technologies you
shouldn't really be building anything
that you can do with the amazing
changing environment of the providers
certainly Google and others that have
capability that you can use and you need
to really focus on making it
prescriptive for your industry for your
domain and then you can really lean into
Data product life cycle data
monetization
privacy engineering and considering
interesting ways to you gen use
generative AI like synthetic data
generation right those things require a
foundation in the things that are on the
left
so this is the first part this is the
assessment on the bottom I've given just
some very simple examples in
organizations we've encountered where
they have push and pull between a chief
technology officer a chief data officer
Etc I was fortunate to have Enterprise
architecture and Cloud at the same time
that I was doing my role as a data
officer and so in looking at that span
it all came down to the people business
stakeholders pilots who were willing to
go first into the cloud environment who
are willing to go first into doing data
science and data exploration
having a way in a venue for them to do
that in a physical environment in a
cloud environment and starting to change
some of the philosophy about it or how
an organization would make data
accessible to people
now the way that that can be done is
it's often difficult if you have an itis
organization that is driving everything
around technology and never connecting
it to business value
the business stakeholders say well
what's in it for me you're replacing my
Erp system you're making me new use new
tools but I'm still stuck with the same
data that I'm wrangling in an
inefficient way so we start the
conversation now and say this is an
example of 10 business value leavers
I would Advocate that every single data
program and project or product that you
pursue you pick a primary business value
lever and a secondary one and you
directly tie it to and have a
conversation with business stakeholders
and say will you be a pilot I believe we
can help you support Regulatory
Compliance I believe we can help you
have faster speed to Market can we
partner up together and do this
initiative seek funding
look at the portfolio determine what
accelerators what code what assets we
have to actually make this a successful
program together instead of I.T trying
to entirely drive it or the business
with Shadow I.T right
so the prompts on the right are intended
to give people a chance to really think
about the maturity
of the organizational construct I know
you're all tired of hearing people
process technology these slides today
and my messages it's not just about the
technology the other two are actually
what makes it sustainable the process
and the people
this is also about making difficult
choices to Sunset
we have
a obligation to be stewards in our
organizations for the financial rigor of
our portfolio Cloud costs often are very
underestimated
so unless you have a phenops program or
a budding phenops program or at Cloud
Center of Excellence that's managing
that and you're resourcing your tagging
it can be completely out of control
so when you look at it as a cost takeout
which is you know again part of this
value lever
how do you tie the return on investment
for a data program and also at the same
time say hey we're going to Sunset these
six things
by putting in this new Cloud
infrastructure some new Services
self-service apis microservices data is
a product a data Marketplace you have to
tie the two together they can't be
independent
and then I would say lastly Persona LED
design there is an explosion in the many
types of
personas in an organization you have
data analysts data scientists data
Engineers software engineers
devops I mean there's many
the the biggest thing that matters is
when you think about the capability
matching to the personas so if you want
to implement you know a new set of
sandboxes and data exploration you have
to really think about who's going to
interact with this what is a reasonable
expectation of skill Readiness risk
complexity for a data analyst in a
business division to log in start using
the sandbox start doing data wrangling
with production data
now I don't know about you but there are
some security concerns you can't just be
copying data and have you know it there
has to be some structure and so when you
start to make it persona-led design
you can be much more prescriptive you
can think about role-based access
controls and the things that are
necessary to convince your executive
leadership to convince your security
teams and your risk we will be fully
compliant giving people better access to
data to do their job
has to be governed and stewarded and
shepherded through a process where you
completely rethink how people operate
around data itself
so in talking about the business in it
coming together we did this illustration
to say where is this business and
technology meeting point we call this
the bridge now this was originally
sketched on a cocktail napkin I'm really
excited at how lovely it looks right now
maybe for fun I should include in my
presentations from now on so you guys
can see it but the point is
the data therapy extends to business and
I.T not always seeing eye to eye not
always having a shared understanding of
the value of a project and certainly the
business has far deeper context for the
way data should be used so I want to
talk about data utility for a second
foreign
I want you to think of a grocery store
you're in the grocery store you're going
shopping and you can take anything off
the shelf and you can look at the
ingredients you can look at where it was
manufactured and you know exactly
how it's to be used right you're not
going to go down the dog food aisle if
you're hungry and take a snack and open
the dog food like that's that's poor
utility right you know exactly what that
product's for and how it's supposed to
be used so I want you to think of a data
product that way you have to know the
provenance and the lineage where did
that data product come from what are its
contents how is it supposed to be used
who is supposed to consume it right
then I want you to think about the
pharmacy
so the pharmacy you can't just walk up
to the pharmacy and take something off
the shelves you have to have a
prescription
and so a data product that is privacy
enabled that is security enabled that is
governed is like your own personal
prescription
it's for specific individuals with a
specific utility in need right
so again when we talk about this
business and technology meeting point
there has to be a contextual
understanding for the data itself the
data utility and all of the things that
go with data management that I showed in
the data management Spectrum
the other thing is around time to value
and metrics
we see many organizations
that have great success
in setting up multi-cloud environments
starting to move applications but they
often set aside a few things to come
back to later
one is Mainframe that comes in second
many times and then the other is their
data and analytics ecosystem data
warehouses right and part of the reason
that they have a challenge with
immediately doing that in the same
prioritized list
is because data warehouses start as a
source for people to secure data that
they need to do their job to use some
business intelligence tools to do some
visual Analytics
to use that data for machine learning
models to train machine learning models
but inevitably what happens is someone
has an idea and it's not a bad one to
start tethering restful services to that
data warehouse and it starts with one
like we're just going to have one
service
it's just going to use a little bit of
that data warehouse and then you turn
around and there's 500.
so you want to move your data warehouse
to the cloud and you're like oh we have
operationally valid live production
web services that now depend on that so
then you've got a whole second set of
items that you need to migrate now
business stakeholders when they hear
this
they are not pleased they're like what
do you mean why it's the data warehouse
migrate the data warehouse but then they
realize that they are actually the
consumers of the web services again
transparent to them they might just have
a web interface they're doing their job
and now they're like oh so we have some
technical debt
and so when I say there needs to be an
agreement between the business and I.T
it is having full transparency of the
portfolio of assets everything
application code everything in the data
ecosystem data products that are really
important for defining how business
should be run and modernizing
and that's when we see that project
portfolio data assets business context
that's exactly what I mean the items in
pink
and on the right this is all the fun
stuff that everyone wants to do
we want to do data Ops we want to just
have everything on autopilot so it's
easier for data Ops requires humans you
all know that now the good news is data
observability
metadata there is a proliferation of new
services that do make it easier but it
still requires resources to be dedicated
to change management
and to long-term care and feeding data
Ops ml Ops finops I'm going to make an
analogy how many of you have dogs or
cats
dogs cats birds anything okay
I'm going to make an analogy that
data Ops ml Ops finops it is like pet
ownership
it's forever you get the puppy so cute
you get the food and the cage it's
forever it's not I'm going to play with
it for a day and then it's just going to
figure it out so anything Ops please
remember it's not just that let's say
you do have the resources great we have
15 people we're going to immediately
make them our Cloud apps data Ops ml Ops
Team
but there's upskilling there's obviously
a challenge to find Talent and it has to
be something that changes over time
there's new Services every day there are
new Integrations every day new data
products every day so the care and
feeding of that is pretty significant so
just like the puppy who grows to be an
adult needs more food
there is this process that has to occur
in your executive leadership need to
know it because they may say to you well
if it's Ops and it's automated don't you
need less people well no we don't
because as you're automating there's
just more work there's more there's more
resources there's more assets and you
have to make sure that the business
stakeholders and executive leadership
are all in for a road map that is not
just Innovation but also contains the
change management and the operations
so
I'm going to get a little bit more into
the technical part of the contents
I'm going to start with overly
simplified what do we consider the four
pillars of a modern data platform it's
very simple Cloud native self-service
data as a product API integration
I'm very certain that the majority of
you already have these pillars in some
semblance within your environments
and the example that I'm going to use
here is
everything that you do should tie back
to the business value
everything that you do should tie to the
personas that will interact in that
particular pillar or across the
environment
and you should always think back to the
bridge am I doing something that is
technologically important but I haven't
told any business stakeholders of the
impact right there is always that dance
between the business and I.T that is
what sustains a modern native platform
because the only way that your
technology teams are going to be able to
grow and flourish
is if they are delivering business value
and it's a very disconnected
thing that we see in most organizations
and it's not for lack of interest it's
just not stitching it together and
creating a cohesive community that meet
in the middle of that bridge the bridge
is made of data
so metadata the data itself an
understanding of your systems and
understanding of the portfolio all of
those things it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy when you can
show the value I had this challenge as I
was building My Cloud
and my EA team and our data engineering
and data science functions I had to
prove the value we were delivering so we
created a business value assessment
where you're measuring before during and
after any data program any Cloud program
the actual business value delivered and
making it quantitative it's not fluffy
it's not it has to be numbers use the
data to tell the data story to justify
why you are again wanting to grow
wanting to innovate and have more
control and more opportunity
so this is a overly simplified but I
think important what you know what do we
consider to be part of a data
modernization ecosystem you're going to
notice right off the bat everything is a
service
um I'm not going to get into a
dissertation about data fabric versus
data Mash it's an and not an or
so data fabric obviously deeply rooted
in use of metadata knowledge graphs data
mesh being Federated data governance
I'm giving you the simplest definition
I'm sure there's many more and you all
know that but when we look at it
all of the people in the middle was
lovely little picture is really around
people all going in the same direction
and agreeing on the priorities for their
organization Enterprise organization
offering things as a service when it's
appropriate and upskilling the workforce
through digital fluency and data
literacy
so behind this
there's a reference architecture
I'm sure you'll recognize many of the
things that are in here obviously
everything from connectivity to data
sources all the way through you know
ingestion storage processing insights
and actions this is prescriptive to your
organization you may not need all of the
things shown here in this reference
architecture but a framework
for understanding when and where you
want to create an offering imagine a
service catalog okay think like you know
a shared services organization that has
all of these things in the toolkit we
often use this as a heat map and we give
a maturity score to some of the
individual components here in the
reference architecture and say you know
until you get to a certain maturity
point we probably don't recommend you do
you know X or Y and so this can be a gut
check for an individual business area
that's maybe very opportunistic and
excited to do data science but you say
to them and still you until you start to
certify your data and have you know
profiling and understand the quality of
your data you really shouldn't start to
advance into some of the other things
you also have to have agreement
there is only so much funding there is
only so much time in people
and the modernization ecosystem
it's always best suited if you have a
few Pilots so I'm a big advocate for
that if you have areas that are ready to
go and they want to lean in and they you
know yes we want to invest our time and
energy and be part of this modernization
effort they become your biggest fans
hands down
they don't want to hear I.T talking
about how great the new Cloud
environment is but you get two business
people that had a successful experience
standing up a new Cloud environment and
they have access to data and analytics
in a sandbox and apis you can there is
not enough money in the world to get
something that good because the business
stakeholders they get the momentum
inside the organization to tell the
story about how this investment was
worth it why it's adding value and then
you're giving them away with those 10
value levers to quantify it yes we did
sell X number of widgets yes we were
able to improve efficiency you know by a
certain percentage
and then what it comes down to is and
you're going to recognize all the logos
on here having something that is the
best in class
Cloud native service catalog
right
now this also means interweaving into it
and I use a very specific example here
those ml flow and accelerators you see
KPMG ignite that's our AIML like we're
making and eating or in dog food here
right
insert your accelerators your code your
scripts the things that make you you in
your organization your assets
lay those on top of your Cloud
deployment plane
put a wrapper around them have a team
dedicated to launching those you don't
need to reinvent the wheel when it comes
to the base Services because they're
they're Best in Class
regardless of
the portfolio of services you chose your
Enterprise architecture to it you chose
the vendors you're working with your
partners leverage those relationships do
code development it's going to get you
to Market much much faster and there are
also some things here that are really
important like having a certification
process raw clean processing trusted
whatever you want to call it Medallion
architecture gold silver bronze
everybody's got a different name for it
a tiered architecture around curating
your data products is absolutely
essential but there has to be agreement
what does it take to certify
what is the criteria that has to be hit
if you think about a data product and we
go back to the grocery store example
would you put something on the shelf
that isn't top quality
think about the ingredients think about
the provenance of it will people
understand it will they consume it
properly
foreign and then lastly the consumption
so I've given just a couple exam this is
not a comprehensive
architectural diagram here this is just
an example of use cloud native Services
determine where you're missing
anything specific maybe it's a policies
code tool maybe it's a generative AI
synthetic data generation tool perhaps
it's some other industry specific
service that you require for
doing business insert those things make
sure that everyone in the Enterprise
knows how to use those services and make
sure that the integration includes all
of the same criteria you would have for
your own data products and your own
assets
is there data observability is there
monitoring is there alerting is it
sustainable is it scalable
is it cost prohibitive right all of
those things should be true whether it's
your internal solution your internal
code base whether it's Cloud native or
whether it comes through a system
integrator a vendor Etc
data's a team sport so it's also around
extending that community that we showed
with the bridge it's business I.T and
then there's like an asterisk on I.T
it's all your partners and all your
vendors
and those that you're interacting with
this is um just to return to the data
product lifecycle there's one item I
want to call out here and I do want to
reserve a few minutes for questions
there is an entirely new category of
data products I call them derived data
products they are anything that is the
output of this certification process now
this process will be very familiar and
comfortable to anyone that does the
software development lifecycle
however for business stakeholders
knowledge workers partners and others if
they're not actively in the software
development life cycle this may feel
very uncomfortable to them they're like
what do you mean I have to start doing
proactive and reactive data governance
sector what does that even mean I have
to do a data quality scorecard I have to
check it into the data Marketplace these
are things that they won't be familiar
with so show them Grace
and help people understand that the data
product life cycle or the data
development life cycle
it's going to be okay
and just like they are accustomed to
seeing applications development done and
software delivered to them
show that overlap show that then and say
we're going to follow a similar process
whether you are waterfall agile agile
something else whatever the familiarity
is for the methodology that you're
following for delivering applications
and services start to intermingle those
data product life cycle components and
then when you get to the point that you
have a derived data product and that is
two data products being used together
the output of an AIML model right a new
data product that didn't exist before
maybe for the first time ever you're
giving a business division access to
data that they were never able to have
before and they take that and do some
amazingly creative things with it well
that derived data product can be
certified and it can be put in a data
Marketplace and it can be shared the
level of innovation and creativity is
unlimited if you look at data products
the right way and really getting into
that curation process you're also
empowering data owners and data stewards
to finally understand that there's a
definition for for these jobs that
they've been doing they didn't even
realize how important it was to the
curation of data for the Enterprise
and then lastly because again we've got
to talk about AI a little bit I want to
share another example
of something that's a Cornerstone for
how you operate in the future around a
modern data ecosystem this is our
responsible AI framework I think
everyone should have one hopefully you
are thinking about and forming the
technology people and process
imperatives in your organizations to do
responsible AI I've listed some of the
major themes I hope this will be useful
to you but I've also listed at the
bottom
our accelerator categories again your
own code and your people or your
greatest asset they have the knowledge
to create accelerators whether it be
code Frameworks best practices run books
leverage those people turn some of those
things into assets that are reusable so
you have one data science team that
isn't completely Reinventing the wheel
when there's four other data science
teams in the company that are producing
exactly the same assets so it's really
getting that portfolio concept the
service catalog concept intact don't
just think of your service catalog as
your Cloud native service catalog like
think of it more comprehensively open
the aperture on what you would consider
to be important and start to socialize
that
one of the last things I'll mention is
do a technology conference in-house
so many people don't ever get to
experience this
business stakeholders
they've never been to a Tech Conference
they've never had conversations about
exciting topics about how you can
renovate and transform bring it to them
do an in-house Expo
do a data Expo where you invite
everybody in the company to come
virtually or physically and you open up
the portfolio of all your data products
and all your assets and then you invite
your partners and vendors to come in and
do training
and you and you teach people the
fundamentals of what is a modern data
ecosystem look like how do we all
participate in the team sport
and then it really helps you because
you're going to have Advocates that are
going to help you Lobby when you want to
prioritize certain initiatives
applications development whatever it may
be because then you're going to have a
business person that says I vote for
that too I'm ready to move my workloads
to the cloud I'm ready to get rid of
this old Legacy data warehouse I want a
data Lake I want to start using
services that help me understand my data
better metadata is for everyone
it's not just for I.T people right
metadata is itself a data product that
should be shared leveraged consumed
and so in closing we're going to have
about 10 minutes for questions
these are the things that I think are
top of mind
um like I said
we didn't have the luxury of going down
the rabbit hole on every single
Google cloud service I'm happy to speak
with any of you about them
I think the goal that I wanted to
communicate was please consider the
people in process part of the modern
data ecosystem
because you can build the services
easily you can hook them up
that the data deployment plane is very
clear
if you walk into the Expo there are
hundreds of providers that have tooling
but you have to return it to what is the
business value does this simplify my
technology portfolio does this help me
LeapFrog some capability in the
environment that delivers business value
does it help me reduce my costs
does it simplify or provide something
really satiating while my company is
going through a much longer
transformation fill in the blank of
whatever kind
um but it also has to be driven on
trusted metrics and kpis if you don't
have a data scorecard that has metrics
and kpis for how well you're delivering
data whether it's being adopted consumed
if you don't have metrics on what is the
average time to Value what's the average
time for people to acquire a data set
what is the average time to insights how
many reports do we have have cobwebs on
them and skeletons hanging off the side
because nobody's touched the report in
17 years right if you're not pruning and
you're not keeping yourselves
accountable with data metrics and kpis
on a monthly basis
I would suggest that there's an
opportunity for improvement there and
then certainly organizational alignment
HR organizations are starting to partner
much more closely with itis to redefine
people's job descriptions
citizen data scientists citizen
developers low code no code open source
all of these things have dramatically
changed the types of Technology roles
that are not just relegated to I.T they
exist in the business they exist with
partners and vendors and you want to
make sure that you're retaining your
people by actually adding to their job
description the types of activities
they're doing within this data
modernization ecosystem
and then obviously scalable
infrastructure and services you wouldn't
be here if you weren't interested in
making the most of the latest and
greatest offering but again it's one
facet
um I think it's incredible I'm so
excited about some of the announcements
that were made this morning and I have
one last question before we take
questions from the audience and that is
is your data
spurring people to action
and if it's not
I would really think about go deep into
that data therapy what's missing why
aren't people using all of these data
products why aren't they using the new
system we implemented are you spurring
them to action and if you're not
make it so
that's it for me
[Music]